[Musik]
willkommen zu bild live am morgen das
sind unsere themen virologe christian
drosten in der kritik wissenschaftler
werfen dem forscher vor in seiner studie
unsauber gearbeitet zu haben das
ergebnis der korona studie kinder können
genauso ansteckend sein wie erwachsene
ist das wirklich so wir beleuchten diese
frage gleich großfahndung nach
geiselnahme in psychiatrischer klinik
zwei patienten in nordrhein westfalen
sind auf der flucht unsere reporter sind
vor ort zweiter verhandlungstag im fall
weizsäcker heute will der killer sich
vor gericht äußern
und wir schauen auf die geiselnahme und
auf die flucht zwei patienten einer
psychiatrischen klinik in nordrhein
westfalen sind im moment auf der flucht
die polizei im großeinsatz mindestens
einer der beiden flüchten flüchten denn
er hat ein messer das duo soll
gewaltbereit sein und wir schalten nach
nordrhein-westfalen geschalten zu meinem
kollegen michael engelberg bild reporter
in kleve michael was wissen wir über die
stattgefundene geiselnahme in dieser
klinik ja guten morgen moritz hier aus
dem bedburg-hau hier ist eine große
landesklinik hier werden psychisch krank
unter anderem psychisch kranke
straftäter untergebracht das seien leute
die auffällig waren die einen hang zu
gewalttaten haben die werden dann nach §
63 verurteilt allerdings werden sie dann
in einem maßregelvollzug untergebracht
und das ist zum beispiel der hinter mir
das haus 25 der lwl-klinik in bedburg
hau die beiden männer sollen gestern
abend ein pfleger in ihre gewalt
gebracht haben einer soll ein messer
gehabt haben sie sollen ihn dann
überwältigt haben und irgendwie aus
dieser klinik raus gekommen sein dann
sieht hier auf den bildern gerade dieser
dieses haus ist sehr von maschendraht
umringt hohe mauern und die polizei
versucht jetzt zu klären wo sich die
beiden männer aufgehalten aufhalten
sollen sie sollen den pfleger bedroht
haben und sollen dann auch mit seinem
ford mondeo
geflüchtet sein wie gesagt momentan
läuft ein großeinsatz der polizei und
jetzt muss natürlich innerhalb des
hauses innerhalb der klinik gesehen
werden wie diese männer wirklich viel
haben flüchten können michael gebt uns
doch bitte eine beschreibung der täter
wie gefährlich sind sie wo können sie
sich gerade aufhalten also bedburg-hau
liegt im kreis kleve das ist nah an der
holländischen grenze also hier sind alle
möglichkeit offen vom ruhrgebiet fördern
und ungefähr anderthalb stunden von
dortmund nach nach kleve von von moers
ungefähr 40 minuten also hier ist
wirklich hier ist wirklich alles möglich
ist kann sogar auch sein dass sie sich
noch hier irgendwo in diesem in diesem
waldgebiet wo diese lwl klinik um sich
befindet aufhalten allerdings holland
ist sehr sehr nah und die beiden
scheinen gefährlich zu sein die polizei
warnt extra das dass sie gewaltbereit
sein und das ist auch das typische bild
für leute die nach § 63 in solchen
maßregelvollzug untergebracht werden sie
haben einen hang vorstand zu schweren
straftaten das beschreibt der
staatsanwalt meistens so dass sich für
die allgemeinheit gefährlich sind jetzt
muss man natürlich hier genau klären wie
die genauen umstände bei den beiden
senkte sich noch auf der flucht befinden
und die polizei verhandelt unter
hochdruck nach den beiden gefährlichen
straftätern michael engelberg du
beobachtest die fahndung für uns und wir
schalten immer wieder zu dir
sobald es neue entwicklungen gibt und
wir hören auch in wenigen minuten neue
details von der polizei ganz herzlichen
dank für den moment wir schalten gleich
wieder zu dir in der korona krise gibt
es eine wichtige frage sind kinder
genauso ansteckend wie erwachsene um
diese frage dreht sich eine studie aus
dem institut von christian drosten
leiter der virologie an der berliner
charité und meistbeachtete politischer
berater in der korona krise nach bild
recherchen ist das ergebnis dieser
studie ja kinder sind so ansteckend wie
erwachsene deshalb die empfehlung der
wissenschaftler kita und schulen
schließen das hat weitreichende
politische konsequenzen jetzt wird in
deutschland heftig über diese studie
über das ergebnis über die
schlussfolgerungen
aus dieser studie und unsere recherchen
diskutiert er gilt als star virologe und
in der korona krise als wichtiger
berater der kanzlerin professor
christian drosten
seine erkenntnisse über das corona virus
sie waren mit entscheidend für alle
regierungsentscheidungen in der korona
krise doch bild recherchen ergeben jetzt
drosten lag nach ansicht auch seine
eigenen wissenschaftler mit seiner
wichtigsten corona studie komplett
daneben
es geht um diese studie am 29 april
veröffentlicht durch das institut für
virologie an der berliner charité leiter
dieses instituts professor christian
drosten wichtigste frage der studie
können sich kinder genauso leicht mit
corona anstecken wie erwachsene und die
drosten studie kommt zu diesem ergebnis
kinder können genauso ansteckend sein
wie erwachsene
der dringende appell der forscher
deshalb an die politik aufgrund dieser
ergebnisse müssen wir vor einer
unbegrenzten wiedereröffnung von schulen
und kindergärten in der gegenwärtigen
situation warnen
doch jetzt werfen wissenschaftler aus
zahlreichen ländern den charité vorstand
vor unsauber gearbeitet zu haben
selbst in bostons forscherteam wird
diese kritik geteilt professor leonhard
hält zum beispiel vom institut für
epidemiologie biostatistik und
prävention uni zürich kritisiert die
erkenntnisse müssen mit einiger vorsicht
interpretiert werden
statistik professor dominik liebe von
der uni bonn sagt die statistische
analyse der autoren widerspricht ihrer
zentralen schlussfolgerung und
wirtschafts professor jörg steuer von
der renommierten cornell university in
new york sagt meine leser der charité
studie kehrt ihre stoßrichtung um kinder
also nicht genauso sondern weniger
ansteckend und die kern kritik der
wissenschaftler
für die studie wurden zu wenige kinder
untersucht interessant drosten im fall
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz unter
leitung von kanzlerin angela merkel
schulen und kitas bundesweit zu
schließen bereits am 13 märz posten
selbst wollte sich zu seiner studie nun
auf bild anfrage nicht äußern und
witterte stattdessen lediglich er habe
besseres zu tun bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder hat die
ankündigungen von weitreichenden
allgemeinen lockerungen der kroner
beschränkung in thüringen als fatales
signal bezeichnet er bittet die
verantwortlichen in thüringen darum die
absicht zu überdenken diese lockerung
durchzuführen im zweifel werde bayern
gegenmaßnahmen unternehmen sagte er
und weiter wir werden uns da noch ein
konzept überlegen müssen wie wir darauf
reagieren
ich möchte nicht dass bayern noch mal
infiziert wird durch eine unvorsichtige
politik die in thüringen gemacht wird
betonte der bayerische ministerpräsident
thüringens ministerpräsident bodo
ramelow hatte angekündigt am 6 juni die
allgemeinen landesweit gültigen corona
schutzvorschriften zu lockern
beziehungsweise ganz auf sie zu
verzichten
es war ein angriff aus hass auf die
familie von weizsäcker das opfer der
chefarzt fritz von weizsäcker der killer
gregor es heute sagt er im mordprozess
vor dem berliner landgericht aus im
mittelpunkt des prozesses dürfte auch
die frage stehen ist der angeklagte
psychisch krank wie die
staatsanwaltschaft meint oder gesund wie
der angeklagte selber von sich sagt er
lächelt hinter dem panzerglas im gericht
doch zu seiner wahnsinnstat sagt gregor
es am ersten verhandlungstag kein wort
vor genau einer woche hat der prozess
gegen den mutmaßlichen mörder von fritz
von weizsäcker begonnen
nach nur sieben minuten wird greco es
wieder zurück ins gefängnis gebracht
dabei soll er nach seiner horror tat
noch wie ein wasserfall auf der
polizeistelle geredet haben
der grund für sein schweigen vor gericht
konnte heute gar nichts sagen weil der
sachverständige noch nicht klar gewesen
ist und in folge dessen wird das dann am
nächsten samstag der medizinische
sachverständige war am ersten tag
verhindert
heute sollte es dann zum ersten mal vor
dem berliner landgericht sprechen
der polizei sagte er er habe fritz von
weizsäcker aus hass auf die familie
weizsäcker getötet eigentlich wollte er
den vater des opfers richard von
weizsäcker töten den ehemaligen
bundespräsidenten den mord an richard
von weizsäcker habe er schon seit 30
jahren geplant doch da der
ex-bundespräsident mittlerweile
verstorben ist habe er sich an seinem
sohn fritz von weizsäcker gerecht für
sein grausames vorhaben reiste gregors
extra von rheinland pfalz mit dem zug
nach berlin an weil er im internet von
dem vortrag des arztes gelesen hatte
unterwegs kaufte er sich sogar noch die
tatwaffe ein klappmesser und vor dem
landgericht in berlin ist mein kollege
peter wilke beobachtet den prozess für
uns peter also schweigen am ersten
verhandlungstag dann hieß es vonseiten
der verteidigung der angeklagte tiefere
seiner heutigen aussage entgegen
wie erlebst du den angeklagten den
killer dort im gerichtssaal ja guten
morgen moritz der angeklagte gregor es
ist ein lagerist aus rheinland-pfalz er
wirkte auf mich ja sehr sehr glücklich
eigentlich dort im prozess zu sitzen er
lächelte wie gesagt in die kameras
bereits letzte woche und freut sich eben
auf diese aussage and nicht auspacken zu
können wie er gesagt hat im bauch
besonders wichtig nicht gepixelt zu
werden dass die ganze welt sein gesicht
das gesicht des mutmaßlichen mörders von
fritz von weizsäcker sehen kann
jetzt ist ein zentraler punkt
ist er psychisch krank der angeklagte ja
oder nein
dementsprechend wird auch ja dann die
unterbringung zu entscheiden seien
psychische unterbringung oder gefängnis
er möchte ins gefängnis
seit seiner festnahme saß er hier in der
psychiatrischen abteilung des
gefängnisses im maßregelvollzug
ihm selbst ist aber besonders wichtig
dass er psychisch komplett gesund ist
dass er nicht geisteskrank ist das eben
die staatsanwaltschaft anders sieht dass
er voll schuldfähig ist und für seine
tat möchte er bestraft werden
ja das wird zu klären sein ob das auch
wirklich so ist und da kommt es vor
allen dingen auf die einschätzung des
psychiatrischen gutachters ein
und der wird auch bald verkündet wie
inwiefern schuldfähig greco es ist ein
prozess nach einer schrecklichen tat
beta build beobachtet diesen für uns in
berlin danke dir
und noch eine weiterer dramatischer
kriminalfall beschäftigt heute die
justiz im mai 2009 10 ermordet laurentis
laut staatsanwaltschaft seine kinder und
spritzt ihnen dann bauschaum in die
münder vermutlich um sich an seine ex
frau zu rächen heute wird das
landgericht dresden das urteil über den
sogenannten bauschaum killer fällen
dabei wird die rechte auch die lange
strafakte von lauren tev berücksichtigen
laurent f anfang februar im landgericht
dresden verhandelt wird der brutale mord
an seinen kindern maja und leo sowie der
mordversuch an seiner ex frau marietta f
doch die schrecklichen taten sind nur
der endpunkt einer langen kriminellen
laufbahn des heute 56 jährigen 1996 wird
er das erste mal auffällig erst wegen
verkehrsdelikten dann wegen stalking und
vergewaltigung freiheitsberaubung und
nötigung das opfer seine damalige
freundin auch sie hatte laurent f zuvor
verlassen es folgten verurteilungen
unter anderem wegen unterschlagung und
schleuser tätigkeit 2004 dann das
vorläufig letzte
urteil gegen laurent f wegen
brandstiftung im rahmen eines
versicherungsbetrugs bei seinen
gewalttaten gegen frauen sei ein
psychiatrischer gutachter ein muster
versuchte sich stets erheblich jüngere
frauen und gab sich als väterlicher
versorger wenn sie sich von ihm trennen
wollten im fanta dies als schwere
kränkung und wurde gewalttätig die
staatsanwaltschaft fordert nun
lebenslänglich wegen mordes und
versuchten mordes sollte das gericht dem
antrag folgen kann der bauschaum killer
frühestens nach 20 jahren auf bewährung
entlassen werden
und bernhard schilz beobachtet den
prozess für uns bernard wie verhält sich
hier dieser kindermörder vor gericht ja
guten morgen nach berlin
er hat in den ersten tagen des prozesses
geschwiegen sich gar nicht geäußert und
dann konnte man ihn eigentlich gar nicht
mehr stoppen er redete also über sein
leben von der kindheit an nur die
grausame tat die wir selber aus der
staatsanwalt hat es in seinem plädoyer
eigentlich auf den punkt gebracht er hat
gesagt wir haben erlebt dass er tagelang
reden kann und am ende bleibt schall und
rauch
er zeigt keine reue er zeigt gibt kein
geständnis ab auch wenn die tat
bestreitet und wie begründet er denn die
tat ist es tatsächlich die rache an der
ex frau ja das war auch ein sehr
schwieriger moment sich das wirklich
anzuhören er hat also das rachemotiv
abgestritten in seinem letzten wort und
hat dann gesagt er wäre genauso bestraft
wie seine frau das heißt er sieht sich
als opfer seiner eigenen tat weil er hat
ja auch seine kinder verloren
danke dir ganz herzlich für diese
information von diesem prozess und wir
werden natürlich in unseren nächsten
sendung von diesen prozess und vom
urteil weiter berichten danke dir und
wir schauen auf die aktuelle warnung und
den großeinsatz in nordrhein westfalen
nach einer geiselnahme sind zwei
patienten aus einer psychiatrischen
klinik in
nordrhein westfalen auf der flucht sie
sollen gefährlich seien bewaffnet sein
und die polizei sucht fieberhaft nach
den flüchtigen vor ort ist mein kollege
michael engelberg beobachtet die
situation michael weiß man schon
genaueres wo sich die beiden denn
aufhalten könnten ja noch mal gut morgen
moritz ihr aus bedburg hau aus dem kreis
kleve
also wo die beiden geflüchteten sich
jetzt wohl aufhalten ist noch nicht so
richtig klar
allerdings ist jetzt der polizei
pressesprecher ingo schankweiler zu mir
gekommen und er wird noch mal
genaue details der flucht mitteilen
können so dass wir das wirklich auch aus
erster hand haben herrscht bei der guten
morgen können sie uns noch einmal genau
erklären was ich hier gestern abend
ereignete
gestern abend gegen halb elf haben zwei
männer 43 und 38 jahre alt die im
maßregelvollzug der des
landschaftsverbands untergebracht sind
zwei mitarbeiter
das mache vollzugs als geiseln genommen
kurzfristig die messer bedroht sie haben
dann einen bediensteten in einem raum
eingesperrt und der zweite musste dann
der pforte vorgeben man wolle abfall
nach draußen bringen und so haben die
beiden die quasi in begleitung dieses
mitarbeiters den weg nach draußen
gebannt dort sind sie in ein fahrzeug
stiegen welches diesen mitarbeiter
gehört die schlüssel haben sie im
aufenthaltsraum in der forensik
vorgefunden also moritz du hörst der
film reich vorgegeben mitarbeiter des
hauses zu sein und müll wegzubringen
also das ist wirklich wirklich nicht so
ganz nachvollziehbar wie das denn
wirklich vonstatten gegangen sein kann
allerdings wird die polizei im weiteren
verlauf des vormittags beraten wie mit
dieser lage weiter umzugehen ist wir
werden uns melden sobald es ein update
zur aktualität gibt michael engelberg
bleibt für uns an dieser lage dran ganz
herzlichen dank nach nordrhein westfalen
und wir schauen auf eine anekdote aus
coroner zeiten ja was ist ein saunabad
ohne sauna und ohne bart
diese frage stellen sich gerade die
betreiber der wellnessoase saunabad
großer teich in limbach oberfrohna
sie haben nämlich jetzt im zuge der
korona maßnahmen lockerungen eine
betriebserlaubnis erhalten allerdings
ist die eher ein schlechter scherz
corona irrsinn in sachsen das saunabad
großer teich in der kreisstadt limbach
ist eigentlich gut besucht wegen corona
musste es mit dem märz jedoch dicht
machen nachdem der betreiber ein hygiene
konzept vorgelegt hatte kam nun die
genehmigung zur wiedereröffnung einziger
haken die fünf saunen und den
badebereich dürfen die besucher nicht
benutzten den betrieb sollen schließen
nicht geheim ist und in widerspruch
gegangen
was soll da schon bekommen
eine sprecherin des landkreises zwickau
konnte das auf bild-nachfrage auch nicht
so recht erklären
leider wurde die zulassung des pools für
den badebetrieb im bescheid nicht
explizit ausgeführt so dass der eindruck
entstand dass die zunächst erteilte
genehmigung anschließend mit auflagen
hat absurdum geführt wurde
erst anfang märz war das saunabad von
testbericht de zum beliebtesten in ganz
deutschland gewählt worden für bulger
perthel und seine mitarbeiter bleibt nur
die hoffnung dass sie irgendwann doch
noch ihrem vollen betrieb wieder
aufnehmen dürfen
ja sie ist erst 26 jahre alt aber
arbeitet bereits seit zehn jahren
erfolgreich als model nadine leopold
kennt die laufstege dieser welt lief
bereits zweimal bei der legendären
victoria secret show ist also ein profi
im business jetzt tauscht sie den
laufsteg gegen den gerichtssaal um gegen
die veröffentlichung von fotos
vorzugehen das magazin madame habe nackt
fotos des models veröffentlicht ohne die
zustimmung von nadine leopold einzuholen
nadine ja war dieses fotoshooting auf
ibiza was besonderes wie lief das ab wie
konnte es geschehen dass da fotos
entstehen die sie gar nicht autorisiert
oder veröffentlicht sehen wollten
also bei einem shooting das war ein
komplett ungewöhnliches modeshooting
dieser geflogen
das shooting bei uns rein und es gab
leichte kleidung und dadurch auch um
sicher zu gehen weil eine gewisse art
von nacktheit bei shootings einfach
etwas ungewöhnliches ist weil man sich
ständig in bewegung findet man andauernd
die position verändert man zielt man
sich am umziehen
man verändert die location vom shooting
und darauf ist es aber nicht
ungewöhnlich ist und es war mir einfach
wichtig dann auch der redakteurin
anzieht klar zu machen dass keine
nacktfotos gemacht oder veröffentlicht
werden sollten und die hat mir auch am
set des öfteren versichert dass ich mir
um nichts gedanken machen müsste und
dass das magazin nina wo das
veröffentlichen würde und dadurch gab es
mir gar keine zweifel und der fotograf
zur sicherheit hat mir auch polaroid
vorschauen gezeigt in denen keinerlei
nach besser sichtbar war und dadurch gab
es von mir aus auch keine zweifel und
kleider im schock muss ich dann ein
leben das trotzdem fotos gegen meinen
willen veröffentlicht worden sind und
dadurch spaß mache ich mich dass mir
jetzt dagegen wäre also sie haben ganz
klar nein
gesagt zu nacktfotos noch am set während
diese so entstanden sind aufgrund der
gegebenheiten ist ihnen so was schon mal
passiert dass man obwohl gesagt wird
nein ich möchte nur bedeckt fotografiert
werden das dann fotos einfach genommen
werden ist das normal in der modebranche
nein also wie gesagt wenn wenn der kunde
nur die kleinste art von nacktheit bei
einem shooting an fordert dann muss das
normalerweise bei der
stellenbeschreibung klar und deutlich
gesprochen werden mit meiner agentur und
dann gibt es auch als model hat man auch
das recht dass man sagt okay ich stimme
dem shooting zu oder nicht bei diesem
shooting speziell an
es war kein akt uhding in irgendwelcher
form und dadurch gab es auch keine
zweifel und auch um sicherzugehen dass
fotos sollen nicht veröffentlicht werden
habe ich mich auch ausdrücklich dann an
die redakteurin am set des shootings
gewendet also wie gesagt in zehn jahren
ist mir das noch nie passiert das noch
nie passiert man wird immer respektiert
amas frau es ist auch ein extremer
intimbereich wenn man immer ein
mitspracherecht haben sollte und nein
muss dann auch immer akzeptiert werden
und sie gesprächen das mitspracherecht
an werden fotos nicht vor der
veröffentlichung wenn sie dann wirklich
fertig bearbeitet sind nochmal ihn
vorgelegt und wie gehen sie denn jetzt
gegen das magazin gegen den verlag vor
ja also leider ist es auch so dass wie
gesagt bei dem shooting mir war nicht
bewusst dass nacktfotos dieser art
überhaupt existierten und wie gesagt da
mir auch vorschau angezeigt wurden und
miranda versichert worden ist das soll
fotos nie veröffentlicht werden also gab
es bei mir auch gar keine zweifel und
leider passiert es auch viel zu oft bei
jungen models dass die aber nicht ernst
genommen werden oder dass sie dann
ausgebeutet und missbraucht werden und
dadurch hat als jetzt auch gesagt ist
einfach so wichtig dass ich mich gegen
gegen so etwas wäre und dadurch dann
doch war es für mich jetzt auch keine
frage an sich gesagt bin seit zehn
jahren in der branche
ich habe die krise so viele meiner ziele
erreicht muss es jetzt einfach wirklich
gerechtigkeit
für alle jungen mädchen einzusetzen und
ja leider muss man das vor gericht
klären um eine veränderung in der
branche zu bekommen
und ja also wir sehen was jetzt passiert
mitspracherecht ganz wichtig und nein
heißt nein auch bei fotos ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre schilderungen
und dass sie mit diesem fall an die
öffentlichkeit gegangen sind ganz
herzlichen dank
dank eines und fußball-deutschland freut
sich schon auf das bundesliga highlight
heute abend das absolute spitzenspiel
der klassiker borussia dortmund gegen
bayern münchen und wir werden hier bei
bild heute abend ganz groß darüber
berichten ab 18 uhr 15 mit dabei
überraschungsgast mehmet scholl und wir
haben uns bei fußball promis umgehört
was sie erwarten ja ich vertraue
natürlich unseren jungs und ich glaube
an ein schweizer einzig von borussia
dortmund nur der bvb
mein tipp für den klassiker dortmund
gegen bayern ist eins zu zwei aus den
einfachen grund nicht weil ich nicht
dortmund fan wäre weil sie spielen
fantastischen fußball aber ich glaube
dass sich die erfahrung der bayern
durchsetzen wird und ja wenn es darauf
ankommt sind sie normalerweise da und
deswegen bin ich überzeugt davon dass
die bayern ein 220 landen werden
hallo roman weidenfeller hier und ich
tippe natürlich einen drei zu zwei für
meine dortmunder schöne grüße in die
runde
mein tipp poster dortmund ging bei
münchen ist ein eins zu drei
mein tipp ist dortmund gegen bayern 2 2
ich hoffe es wird ein super spiel alles
gute 3 2 auswärtserfolg für die bayern
beim bvb und dann wissen spannender noch
im kampf
die verbleibenden chemischen hessischen
okay bereits gestern abend gab es
hierbei bild ein box highlight wir haben
den legendären kampf rocchigiani gegen
maske noch einmal in voller länge
gezeigt mit ganz besonderer
kommentierung von henry maske setzt
jetzt kommt der moment wenn sich die
boxer eigentlich in die augen schauen
soziale kogler und wollte ihn fixieren
aber er ließ sich nicht für richtig
ja ich komme und sorgen für jeden
normalausleger ist ein rechtsausleger
gift warum weil er zu selten bedient
taten mit ihm arbeitet für einen
rechtsausleger als normales
normalausleger was ganz
selbstverständlich ist weil wir ja fast
immer mit normalausleger zu tun haben
für uns ist ein rechtsausleger genauso
gift was hier schon erkennbar ist eine
typische art zu boxen kann ich hier
schwer nicht durchsetzen
bis dann auf meiner seite jetzt kaum
schöner treffer von ihnen zu mir wir
sind auf erzählten dann noch einer ist
dann hier man sieht ja ich bin ja doch
deutlich näher einer distanz also von
draußen nicht mehr sondern eher
halbdistanz ich glaub mir ich bin nicht
ich bin nicht im kopf irgendwie
angeschlagen ich bin so kaputt graziano
wird noch motiviert sich noch einmal
zusammenzureißen aber der ist genauso
kaputt nicht überzeugen darum geht's
aber in rheine kämpfer nicht so knappen
kampf bei seiner gattin situation bei so
einem deutlichen ja ein legendärer kampf
wir schauen noch mal nach
nordrhein-westfalen wir haben wir
versprochen sie immer auf dem laufenden
zu halten
die großfahndung nach zwei flüchtigen
patienten aus einer psychiatrischen
klinik in nordrhein-westfalen sie läuft
nach wie vor sie wird beobachtet von
unserem bild reporter michael engelberg
michael du hast uns schon beschrieben
wie möglicherweise die beiden aus der
anstalt flüchten konnten
weiß man mehr wohin sie sich ja jetzt
begeben haben könnten wie sie auf der
flucht sind per fahrzeug per fuß was
weiß man da genau was ja hallo moritz
noch einmal guten morgen hier aus
bedburg hau aus dem kreis kleve
man geht nach wie vor davon aus dass die
beiden flüchtigen noch mit einem auto
unterwegs sind welches sie hier dem
schläger quasi abgenommen haben und
damit dann geflüchtet sind neben mir
steht aber immer noch der pressesprecher
der polizei in kleve
herr schankweiler jetzt ist der einsatz
sie haben wir gerade selber gesetze sind
auch seit einer schon schon im dienst
jetzt wie wird die polizei weiterfahren
wird das umfeld jetzt umgekrempelt wie
kann man da von damit umgehen dass jetzt
zwei wirklich schwere straftäter auf
freien fuß ja gut wir haben natürlich
erstmal in polizeilichen
informationssystemen die beiden zur
fahndung ausgeschrieben das fahrzeug ist
zur fahndung ausgeschrieben
darüber hinaus laufen natürlich
landesweiter erkenntnis austausche der
blick geht sicherlich auch in richtung
niederlande
und sie versuchen die spuren aufzunehmen
wo die beiden sich aufnehmen aufhalten
könnten
und im laufe des tages hoffen wir dann
auch mit namen und bildern zu kommen und
dann sind wir natürlich zwangsläufig
auch ganz wichtig auf die hinweise aus
der bevölkerung angewiesen
dann sagen sie uns bitte noch eben wie
muss man sich verhalten wie soll man
sich verhalten wenn man meint die beiden
gesehen zu haben
wichtig ist insbesondere aufgrund der
umstände dass es durchaus mit
gewaltbereiten menschen zu tun haben
hier nicht den helden zu spielen sondern
die polizei zu informieren im handy
zeitalter ist das heute auch über die
110 kein problem
den kontakt zu halten personen zu
beschreiben möglicherweise versuchen den
kontakt zu halten und zu warten bis
hilfe kommt
zu warten bis hilfe kommt 110 kein
problem und nicht den helden spielen ich
denke das passt das zusammen wo man sich
jetzt als als bürger dran halten sollte
wenn man die beiden flüchtigen sieht wir
geben erst mal zurück nach berlin und
melden uns wenn es neuigkeiten gibt
michael engelberg ganz herzlichen dank
ja und jetzt noch zum thema urlaub 2020
können wir in diesem jahr in
griechenland urlaub machen bild hat ein
exklusives interview mit griechenlands
premier georgis im mitsotakis geführt er
hat eine botschaft an uns alle auf
deutsch dann kommen sie in der kirche
land das wetter ist wunderbaren wir
möchten viele deutsche touristen in
griechenland dieses dieses jahr hat und
wie das gehen soll das klären wir heute
in einer sondersendung um 13 uhr urlaub
in griechenland
dort sehen sie dann auch das komplette
interview mit dem griechischen
premierminister kyriakos mitsotakis
außerdem alle wichtigen infos zum thema
urlaub in griechenland das war bild live
am morgen wir sind um 12 wieder mit live
am mittag bis dahin
[Musik]